you know what up what up blog very
special episode of daily sheet the
incredible women that our foundation at
vaynermedia I think you could enjoy this
I'm gonna make a little mix up a little
twist up a little different angle on
what we do here recognizing some of the
incredible people are this very special
day I hope you enjoy this special
episode of Bailey shape
[Music]
my name is tatiana st andrew yoga i am a
director of account strategy here at
vaynermedia hi good morning on my yume
tatsuta and i'm a group creative
director hi I'm Jen Bank I'm a business
operations manager and associate
creative director the best part about my
job and what I do every day is the fact
that I get to if I do it right I get to
cultivate people's talents and ensure
their success not just here at Vayner
but also you know outside of here beyond
here for the longevity of their career I
think what's really nice about this idea
and this type of work is that you know
it really encourages the brand to have
such an honest conversation where their
audience so it seems so authentic it is
authentic but what's also great it's
like this is the type of work that I
think is most powerful right because we
are igniting a conversation we're
sparking conversation that has to be had
within this audience within our industry
within you know this generation being
exposed to so many people who have not
so hidden talents really great strengths
and weaknesses that help you grow and
help challenge yourselves as well and so
it's just been a personal journey of
growth and professional - I love the
fact that the the name on the door that
we walk through every single day I love
the stuff that he says like who gives a
[ __ ] like it does not [ __ ] matter
like don't worry about what they say
they will always be haters whether it's
your parents don't believe in what you
do your friends like you know cultural
norms like like who gives a [ __ ] like if
you love what you do like just walk
through those doors every single day and
on it like it really does not matter
like we just have to stop this whole
like they might be thinking this might
they might be saying that who cares I
think it really doesn't matter all that
matters is that you believe in what you
do and that you go for and you feel like
you're giving your best every single day
my badass female role model is
Amelia Earhart hot when people said to
her hey you can't fly across the
Atlantic solo she was like hey hold on
hold my beer
besides Oprah and my mom it's Easter ray
she was just an awesome creative but
creative guys I wouldn't cook up to her
but you do it for TV and this bird
people like me my mom because she taught
me everything and taught me to be a
confident woman that doesn't take [ __ ]
from anybody a one who is at me M is
Natalie Carey natalie is all of the
organization that I would want to have
in my life but also just brings
incredible empathy to every team that
she's ever worked on I'm and I admire
her immensely for a woman who gave me
the job at vaynermedia romy name she was
the first person to believe in me and my
potential and give me a shot and
strategy learn how to self promote and
know that it's okay because you have to
undo all the training that you've had in
school where you raise your hand wait to
get called on and then get to speak so
just having to undo all that training
knowing that it's okay to speak for
yourself and speak on behalf of others
advocate for them as well as something
that I've learned while being at Boehner
and would love to share with everyone -
how did you get some confidence to undo
that like
I guess it's when you're towing that
line between like what's expected of me
and what is truly me and being able to
better understand you know what am i
doing for myself how am I supposed to
make this job work for me like Miami was
just saying because I had to flip that
mentality of me being a worker bee
because that's sort of how I was all my
life and having to move up and become
more of a managerial person person meant
that I had to take that next step and
also show the weight for others as well
the advice I give to women starting off
in this business right now I'll even
when you're on staff act like a
freelancer or think like a freelancer
like don't think that you work for the
company make the company work for you
you're surrounded hopefully by some of
the most talented smartest people in
this business in this industry you're
surrounded by tools resources you know
take all that grasp all that and and
turn make opportunities for yourself
don't ever think that you're working for
this company oh I have a job I wear the
stuff you know make the company work for
you it's like it's a it's an
accountability thing it's about like
being responsible and wherever you are
like owning those opportunities and
owning that and taking responsibility
for your own success and for the success
of the team and so I would say my advice
is to not apologize and to to to to own
the position that you're in and find
that success and figure things out for
yourself and and make and make those
inroads and advocate for yourself and
and manage that manage down manage side
to side like in in every way it's it's
really about like being accountable and
taking responsibility for for where you
are an opportunity you have in and your
success I realize now that my the
perspective that I bring to the job
every day is what sets me apart and is
my strength and so if I like it's like
the more you can tap into who you are
the more specific the work is and then
you're gonna drive those business
results because it's going to resonate
so don't be afraid to really let that
that show up in
with your colleagues and don't be polite
if you're not flight you know but yeah
keep it professional but yeah really
bringing the whole self to work everyday
I think just makes the work better be so
good they can't ignore you so I feel
like the the work and the hustle piece
for me is like I'm I'm gonna be so good
at my job that it doesn't matter and
really focusing on like the objectivity
of of of being good and being successful
and putting the work in and that's like
the accountability piece is like be so
good that it doesn't matter and focusing
on your skill set and being successful
and and putting the work in is the
advice I would give the best piece of
advice was actually from an Instagram
post from kpop here at Vayner experience
she said she doesn't do anything for the
fame she shows it all through her
actions so stop talking and start doing
[ __ ] so yeah the best piece of advice
I've ever received is always negotiate
your salary because no one's gonna watch
out for how much money you make except
for you stop comparing yourself to
others you're on your own journey and it
might take unexpected roads but you'll
eventually get there hey I'm so glad to
be a female leader here at vaynermedia
I'm proud of the fact that this is a
video that's showcasing some of our
amazing female talent and male talent
too we've got a 50-50 split here at
Vayner and it's something that we are
proud of a showcase every single day so
rock on thanks for watching and we'll
see it
[Music]